today on the matt welsh show a man who'd
already been arrested 41 times in new
york city is arrested again for violent
assault we know that leftist da's are
allergic to punishing violent criminals
but why is the left so determined to
enable and spread crime and anarchy i
think i know why and i'll explain also
the buy administration mulls its options
as a student loan pause nears its
expiration date a christian private
school causes outrage by in stating
christian policies and rules if you can
imagine that brian stelter has his final
emotional tragic show with cnn and we're
told that a new trend is taking the
workforce by storm it's called quiet
quitting what is it
and is it as stupid as it sounds we'll
discuss all of that and more today on
the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
well the consumer price index has
reached yet another 40-year high and the
latest gdp numbers confirmed that the
united states is in a recession despite
the fact that our current administration
is trying to redefine what recession
means during the 2007 recession
washington mutual lehman brothers
chrysler multiple blue chip stocks went
down to zero overnight could that happen
again if so how confident are you that
your savings are protected now is not
the time to have all your money in the
stock market or tied to the us dollar
take action to protect your savings from
a highly turbulent economy now by
diversifying at least some of your
investment portfolio into gold and
silver from birch gold group text walsh
to 989898 and birchgold will send you a
free information kit on how to
transition an ira or eligible 401k into
an ira in precious metals birchgold will
even help you hold gold in a tax
sheltered account for decades investors
have relied on gold and silver as a
hedge against inflation now you could do
the same with an a plus rating with the
better business bureau countless
five-star reviews and thousands of
satisfied customers secure your future
with gold from birch gold now text walsh
to 98 98 98 and get help from birch gold
today again text walsh to 989898 to
claim your free no obligation
information kit on how to protect your
hard earned savings with gold
last week a man named alexander wright
showed up at a subway station in new
york city and began harassing other
patrons a subway worker witnessed right
accosting people and tried to intervene
right then walked up to him and punched
him in the head then the victim tried to
run away but was grabbed and thrown to
the ground the assailant was later then
arrested
it was for alexander wright
the 42nd arrest
he had already been arrested 41 times
before this
many of those arrests were for acts of
violence even more brutal than his
attack on the subway employee just last
year wright was caught on camera
randomly punching an asian woman in the
head as she walked by knocking her to
the ground
now it's not that difficult to kill
somebody with one punch to the head
especially if they're not expecting it
and especially when you're so much
bigger and stronger than your victim
fortunately though the victim survived
wright was hit with hate crime and also
assault charges other charges too and
yet he was back on the street almost
immediately
a month before that assault on the asian
woman he had been charged with assault
for throwing a hot coffee on two traffic
cops
so to summarize this man has been
walking the streets of new york city for
years
viciously assaulting and brutalizing
pedestrians the system is aware of him
they know that he's out there they they
know what he will do to people
uh they know he'll never stop and yet
they allow him to remain on the streets
his freedom
is worth the cost they've decided even
if the cost is the physical safety of
innocent people
now there are of course many such cases
our cities are full of alexander rights
and they're not just terrorizing the
poor areas anymore as the daily wire
reports today lawlessness abounds across
new york city neighborhoods like the
west village in greenwich village which
have seen the largest spike in crime
this year out of the five boroughs
according to the latest new york city
police department report published last
week compared to the crime stats from
the same time last year manhattan's
sixth precinct saw an 80 percent
increase in overall significant crimes
with burglaries up 119 and grand
larcenies up more than 100 percent
business owners and residents have
spoken to media outlets airing their
frustrations of the lack of law and
order in a neighborhood that draws
celebrity sightings historic brownstones
and gentrified taqirias on roofs amid
the fashion and art scene
jama alsner who owns village revival
records in greenwich village told cbs2
he rarely calls the police anymore
because anything seems to go these days
according to the latest data other crime
statistics show car thefts are up 39
robberies reach up to 45
and uh rapes are up nearly 43
now this trend holds up across the
country as the violence from the inner
city bleeds further and further out into
the areas that were once considered safe
now you might think that this would be
enough to finally spur some change and
maybe a little bit of a revival of law
and order
now that the urbanite liberals who
support the policies that have caused
this anarchy are finally being made to
reap what they've sown
perhaps things will change
but that seems unlikely because they're
still leftists and leftism at this point
is hopelessly nihilistic deluded
destructive and utterly severed from
reality
as long as the cities are run by this
suicidal ideology things will just not
get better crime is a among other things
a practical problem and leftists
floating as they are in an alternative
universe are not capable of solving any
practical problems in this universe
whatsoever
least of all a practical problem like
crime
because it has some not as practical
dimensions to it which we'll get to in a
second
anna kasparian over at the young turks
is is learning
this lesson about the left the hard way
in a fascinating career shift kasparian
has recently tried her hand at something
very new and novel for her she's tried
making logical points
specifically on the issue of crime she
has in recent days ever so gingerly
dipped her toe into the waters of logic
and reason but she's discovering that
she can't wait into those depths without
alienating herself from her leftist
comrades
that's why she's been getting into a lot
of trouble on the left for saying things
like this listen to this
i don't know maybe i'm crazy i don't
believe in the death penalty
but i would say that if you uh murder
someone
and you have spent time in a facility in
a prison that does not rehabilitate
because that's what our prisons are
it's very unlikely that you're
rehabilitated and just releasing you
into the world with no rehabilitation
bad idea
bad idea
more than 63 000 inmates convicted of
violent crimes will be eligible for good
behavior credits that shorten their
sentences by one-third instead of
one-fifth that had been in place since
2017 that includes nearly 20 000 inmates
who are serving life sentences with the
possibility of parole
keep in mind by the way we don't even
know
how these good credits are
determined there's really no specificity
there
more than ten thousand inmates convicted
of a second serious but non-violent
offense under the state's three strikes
law will be eligible for release after
serving half their sentences that's an
increase from the current time served
credit of one-third of their sentence
and if you think that
no come on anna they're just
they're not releasing violent criminals
even though the reports indicate they
are they're just this is all about
non-violent individuals no actually a
much smaller portion of the individuals
who have been released from california
state prisons are non-violent offenders
well so you mean that you mean that if
you release violent criminals out into
society
you're going to end up with more violent
crime
in society
next you're going to tell me that if you
pour water into a cup
you'll end up with water in a cup
you know these sorts of claims may not
seem terribly shocking to you and i but
on the left such talk is verboten
casparian has been getting pilloried for
even the most tepid suggestion that
perhaps our laws against violent crime
should be enforced
a reporter for
rolling stone was among the leftists
taking her to task and kasparian
responded referencing the alexander
wright case saying
this is a man who was arrested 41 times
after this incident he was released and
went on to send a subway worker to the
hospital with a broken collarbone
but according to this crime reporter the
man committing assault breaking bones is
the real victim
well yeah anna welcome to the left
been there for a while should have
noticed this by now
the responses under her tweet show you
how far
how far gone the left is on this top
again on any other topic of course
reading just a few uh someone says you
can debate whether or not a 49 year old
mentally ill homeless man is a victim
but there's not a lot of evidence that
sending him to rikers where most people
are pre-trial and so legally innocent is
a solution that improves public safety
another person says i think the issue is
that your position shouldn't just boil
down to this guy sucks punishment that
doesn't help anyone it's not
constructive and shouldn't be a
conclusion made in a program that
positions itself on the left another
person says i don't know the details of
this particular case but what you're
what are you trying to achieve with this
narrative the public hears enough
dishonest fear-mongering about crime
left alt media should offer something
different such as exploring root causes
of crime and another person more to the
point says you should feel a deep sense
of shame anna
yes anna should feel ashamed
well she probably should feel ashamed of
a lot of things but but should you feel
ashamed of suggesting that perhaps after
40 arrests it might be time to put
somebody in jail for longer than 15
minutes
perhaps we could adopt a 40 strikes on
your out rule can we do that 40 strikes
no because even that would be offensive
to the left
they see no evidence that the public is
made safer
when violent criminals are kept in
prison
they say no there's no evidence to them
that you are safer from a violent
criminal when he's behind bars
as opposed to if he was like right in
front of you there's no evidence that
one is safer than that they presumably
also see no evidence that patrons at the
zoo are made safer when the door to the
lion's cage is closed and locked as
opposed to open
it's totally neutral either way if they
were at the zoo and the zookeeper said
you guys want this open or closed you
care but whatever it doesn't matter what
difference does it make
there's literally no difference between
looking at a line when he's in a cage
and confronting him out in the open with
nothing between the two of you no
difference
this is the delusion that permeates the
left
so i thought i would try to help our
friend anna um understand
why she's getting this reaction from her
own compatriots and why anybody on the
left
any democrat
who
and very few of them ever do but every
once in a while one of them will say
something like this hey you know maybe
this violent crime thing is a little bit
of a problem
and they just get devoured by the
piranhas and let me try to help you
understand why that is
now part of it is the delusional nature
of modern leftism as we've already
discussed this is what makes makes
leftist political leaders totally
incapable of providing actual leadership
their ideology requires them to live and
think as though they've been transported
through a portal into an alternate
dimension and in this dimension the
usual rules of life and the laws of
physics and everything else don't apply
here in this alternate dimension men can
have babies babies aren't people and
many other bizarre occurrences become
commonplace even the laws of cause and
effect no longer apply releasing a
violent criminal from prison
has nothing to do with the fact that the
violent criminal was then enabled to
violently victimize someone else even if
he'd still been in prison
the same event may have occurred they
say
now this makes no sense in reality when
you understand cause and effect
but these people are not living in
reality
but there's a deeper point here also
and this is this is the part that i want
everyone to focus on especially anna
you know ironically
these people who call who we call social
justice warriors
and i don't like that phrase and this is
why because they actually have no
concept of justice at all
it's kind of like we talk about virtue
signaling but the people that are
signaling their virtue are signaling the
opposite of virtue it's like most of
what we call virtue signaling is
actually vice signaling
so most of what we call social justice
you know
is actually it's anti-justice it's the
opposite of justice it's the absence of
justice
after all
putting violent criminals in prison
is not just a matter of keeping people
safe it's also a demand of justice
and most normal and healthy people have
an innate sense of justice
okay they see a man randomly assaulting
a woman as she walks down the street
and they want him to be punished
severely for his crimes
that's not vengeance it's not bloodlust
it is justice
okay they see that action as one that
cries out for a response
the scales have been tipped out of
balance and they must be righted there
must be justice
even if it were possible to keep society
safe from this man without punishing him
a normal person would still want him
punished
you want him to experience some measure
of suffering for his crime
yes that is just you actually want him
to suffer
and if you care about justice and also
if you actually have love and compassion
for the victim
which is nothing that doesn't exist on
the left as much as they talk about
compassion and love there's none of that
it's indifference
but if you actually have compassion for
the victim
you want that other guy to suffer
because that is justice
justice is a virtue
it's a cardinal virtue it is in fact the
most important virtue of all
you can't have any other virtue without
justice
and it is what ensures that an
individual is given what they are do
okay i think that would be the
definition of what is justice that's the
definition it is giving an individual
what they are do
to enact justice
is to give to a person
what properly belongs to him
and what properly belongs to an innocent
person walking down the street is
protection from violent scumbags like
alexander wright
but what properly belongs to alexander
wright
is a cage
he should be punished
because that is what he is due
that is what he is owed
that is the treatment which naturally
and properly belongs to him
because of his own actions
and because of the sort of person he has
chosen to be
this is something that again doesn't
need to be explained to the average the
average person you ask them what is
justice
just like if you ask them what is a
woman
they may be stumped by the question only
because the answer is so obvious they
haven't even had to think about it
but that is what justice is
and unless you are fighting for that
you're not fighting for justice
now let's get to our five headlines
did you know that more than half of
american citizens do not have a will
what many people fail to understand is
that a will is about so much more than
protecting your assets you've heard me
talk a lot about this um subject on my
show about how the left is coming after
your kids they're you know through the
public school system through mainstream
kids content the list goes on as a
parent you may be doing everything you
can to protect your child from the
left's not so secret agenda
but if you don't have a will in place
designating who will take take over as
parental guardian should something
happen to you and the state will
intervene and all of that work is wasted
if you're watching the show i'll wage
your bet that you don't want the state
making those decisions for you that's
why you need to check out epic will epic
will is an online wheel platform that
costs less than your next trip to the
store they can set you up with a will in
as little as five minutes plus uh it's
all starting at 119 and you can save 10
when you go to epicwell.com and use code
walsh take five minutes tonight to write
a will ensuring that your kids will be
raised the way you would have intended
in the event that something should
happen to you go to epicwheel.com
and use my code walsh today to save 10
percent
now before we get to the headlines uh i
need to update you on my latest
marital
battle
so i decided that i wanted to
take my two boys away for a weekend
fishing trip come up here in a few weeks
and my wife is totally supportive of
that actually she's she's maybe a little
bit too supportive
i i cause i i said to her hey i wanted
to take the two boys away yep sounds
good definitely you guys should go 100
so she was pretty enthusiastic
enthusiastic about about us being gone
for whatever reason but then i um
started thinking about the details of
the trip and and what i wanted to do and
i decided that i'd really like to take
to have a more sort of a rustic
experience with the kids i started
looking for a very simple kind of
cabin in the woods somewhere with water
nearby you know whether it's on water we
have to walk to it or drive to it
whatever
and i found this this is real this is
actually for rent i found this this uh
this thing i put it up on the screen um
i asked for a rustic cabin and this is
what i found um and this is this is like
it's a it's a cat it's basically a shed
it's someone's renting out their shed
and but there's a lot of privacy it's
like they said they said in the listing
there's a lot of privacy because it's
out it's in the woods somewhere
and uh and it's about it's about like
200 square feet and there's a tarp for a
roof
and there's no bed there's no furniture
of any kind there's no electricity no
water nothing
and so i'm i showed this stuff i was
excited about i said this the kids will
boys will love this and i showed it to
my wife and she was horrified she looked
at me like i was a an insane person
but then
this just shows you you know this this
shows you the inherent differences
between men and women
because my wife is horrible there's no
way you can take my my precious sweet
baby boys and put them in that for a
weekend i'm not gonna allow it
but then just to get a second opinion i
called my boys in and showed them this
and they were stoked i mean they could
not have been more excited to spend
three days in that thing and i even told
i told my son i said you know um
there's like definitely probably snakes
in this thing
and he said well that's okay daddy we
can kill them and eat them
that's the spirit okay when life gives
you snakes make some dinner
that's the spirit you want to i think
imbue into your into your boys
i don't know i did find another place
that's still a very small cabin in the
woods but significantly nicer than that
and a little bit less
serial killer e but my heart keeps
coming back to that it's just it's
calling my name
and if you stay in that cabin you'll
probably hear all kinds of things
calling to you outside in the in the
woods at night but
it's an adventure
um all right so we'll start with this
daily wire reports education secretary
miguel cardone cardona said sunday that
the byte administration would announce
in the next 10 days
whether or not the nationwide pause on
federal student loan payments and
interest accrual that went into effect
two and a half years ago would extend or
expire during an appearance at nbc's
meet the press
cardona told um host chuck todd that the
administration knows many people are
waiting to hear something about the
august 31st deadline and he said the
next 10 days they're going to announce
something now
let me take a guess here just a wild
crazy guess
that the democrats are not going to let
the pause
expire a few months before the midterms
this like i said it's a shot in the dark
but i'm going to guess that they're
going to come back and announce
something
because they're not going to let it
pause right before the right before the
midterms
and i don't think we need to spend much
time
talking about student loan forgiveness
as an issue you know how i feel about
the subject we've talked about it many
times we'll talk about in the future
um
but i want to just add one thing
because i was thinking about this
yesterday
is that is that actually
it seems to me
and i'm not in favor of loan forgiveness
of any kind okay i'm in favor of
because i'm an old i'm old-fashioned as
you know and what i believe is that you
pay your debts
you pay your debts
you agree to pay something you pay it
back
that's that's how i look at it very
simple
but it does occur to me that actually of
all the different types of debt that
people deal with in many ways student
loan debt makes the least sense to
forgive it should be the last type of
debt that we talk about for giving
rather than being the first and only
type of debt we talk about forgiving i
mean mortgages car loans even credit
card debt these are all things
that working-class people deal with
student loan debt is largely an
upper-class problem half of the debt
around half is held by graduate students
okay
and it's it's exactly though that kind
of debt
that we're forgiving and it's exactly
the kind of debt that poorer people have
to deal with that we aren't talking
about forgiving
now the reason often given for this is
that student loan debt can't be
discharged in bankruptcy and it kind of
makes sense actually in a way why you
can't discharge it in bankruptcy i mean
for one thing
um you know a
a loan or a degree cannot be repossessed
you can't take it back from you
so it can't be discharged in bankruptcy
so that's one of the reasons they say
well you know that's why we that's why
we're treating this as a special thing
that to me seems a pretty weak
justification
for the inordinate amount of attention
given to it
not to mention just the the inordinate
amount of sympathy that we're supposed
to have for people with student loan
debt
while having no sympathy at all for all
the other kinds of people many of them
don't have college degrees many uh many
uh are have have you know on average
incomes much lower than the average
college graduate and they they're
swimming in debt a lot of them
totally ignore the problem
all right we'll move to this so the
prime minister of finland
santa marin is her name
has been taking heat after video of her
partying went viral and this is
something that she does a lot apparently
she likes to go out clubbing she heads
out onto the town
i think if i'm remembering correctly i
think it was this prime minister who
like went missing for
a day or two because she was out
partying and forgot her phone or
something like that
and um anyway here's the video that was
on that i guess they posted on instagram
or something we'll play this video
all right
[Music]
[Music]
okay so there she is having a great time
at the club partying
um there's been she's gotten a lot
there's been a lot of criticism a lot of
discussion about this
and uh she finally responded to some of
the criticisms that will play this and
i'll have to translate
because you know she's speaking a
foreign language but actually no finish
so i'll translate this for you but we'll
go ahead and play the
clip
what do you think these party videos
these videos are private and filmed in a
private space
i resent that these became known to the
public what you posted them i spent a
night with my friends
we just partied also in a boisterous way
i danced and sang uh younger generation
i represent a younger generation
speaking english now okay when it comes
to social media or instagram i think
that i'm an individual a person a real
person also even though i'm a prime
minister so i won't change the way i
behave
of course of course i want to be careful
what i say because it can be
represented as the whole government
but
i'm still a person and i will be
oh you're a person okay that's good that
is the laziest justification for
behavior
in general
someone's asking why you behave well i'm
a person well yeah i know but
you're a person who did this particular
thing lots of other people don't do that
so can you explain a little bit more i'm
just a person
she says she resents that it ended up on
social media
you're dancing in front of a video it
came it's like someone has their phone
out and you're dancing in front of it
looking right into the camera
i resent that this video i'm taking
right now exists i resent this
now this has led to a whole annoying
discourse there's nothing worse than a
discourse in our country and this
discourse in particular is pretty bad
it's a discourse about whether
um
prime ministers have the right to party
and the ap actually asks this
specifically in an article headline
does a prime minister have a right to
party
now we know the beastie boys we know how
they would answer they would say if you
fight for you have the right to it but
this is what the ap says in a leaked
video finland's prime minister santa
marin is seen dancing and singing with
friends at a private party the 36 year
old leader poses for the camera she sits
on her knees hands behind her head she's
entangled in a group hug she's having a
good time countless similar videos are
shared daily on social media by young
and not so young people partying in
finland and all over the world but the
leak has triggered a debate among finns
about what level of reveling is
appropriate for a prime minister
especially considering neighboring
russia's attack on ukraine which
prompted long neutral finland and sweden
to apply for nato membership marin who
leads the center-left social democratic
party has faced a barrage of questions
about the party were there drugs was
there alcohol was she working or on
summer vacation was the prime minister
sober enough to handle an emergency had
one arisen
the video clearly shot by someone at the
party was leaked on social media and
caught the attention of finnish media
this week okay
so i just want to make a couple points
about this very briefly
first of all
prime minister or not
you're too old to be out at clubs and
that sort of thing when you're 36
anyway it doesn't matter if you're prime
minister even if she wasn't
even she just worked at starbucks or
something she was like assistant manager
at starbucks i would say
you're a little too old for that i'm 36
okay so we're the same age
at 36 you should be home with your
family
okay you could go out for a date night
with your spouse
uh you could also go out with friends on
occasion but people are talking about
this woman
and excusing it like oh she's young just
doing what young people no she's not
that young actually you're 36 it's not
that young
it's you're middle-aged
that's that's what you are you are
officially you don't really count as a
young adult anymore
you're you're middle age you're getting
older
and so
especially at 36 you should be
you should be at the age now where you
walk into a place
and
not only are you not dancing to that
music but you're complaining that it's
too loud
i'm officially at the age where
everywhere i go
the music is too loud and i have to make
a comment about how loud the music is
that is what makes sense for a 36 year
old
to begin with
second she is the prime minister
and i get that it's just finland and
there's like five people that live there
but but even so
this to me is part of a of a larger
problem
with political leaders in general
and this sort of lack of of seriousness
we're not being led by serious people
and there used to be this concept called
just dignity
among our leaders
there used to be a concept called
dignity that we tried to apply to all
adults and everybody in general
which again is another reason why that
would stop you know even if you're not
prime minister it should stop you from
being a 36 year old woman
making videos like that
but even so especially if you're a
leader we expect even more dignity
and and what does dignity mean okay
dignity doesn't mean
sometimes i think dignity gets a bad rap
these days and especially because it's
often appropriated by political leaders
especially like republicans will use
this the squishiest republicans will use
dignity as their excuse for being
squishy so dignity has become somehow a
synonym for like cowardice or lack of
conviction
these they don't want to fight hard for
what they supposedly believe in and they
use dignity oh cause i'm dignified
no no you
you can still be dignified and fight for
what's right that's part of dignity
actually but what dignity means is it's
dignity is about a seriousness of
purpose that that's what that is
it's about maturity
growth and a seriousness of purpose
and we used to expect that of of elected
leaders
in finland and everywhere else across
the western world and we don't anymore
i mean you've got uh what's his name in
in uh
in pennsylvania the senate race so
there's not a lot of dignity on either
side of that race but uh fetterman
you know have you seen this guy walking
around with like jean shorts
and uh and a hoodie
you're running for the senate
and this is how you're dressing this is
how you're talking to people
well i'm just uh i'm just being a calm
like being a regular person
no but no you're not because regular
people know that you're supposed to
dress differently for different
occasions
so acting with a lack of dignity is is
that's how you that's that's how you see
regular people no
so that's my problem with this
okay let's go
next to uh
this brian stelter had his last show and
um
signed off with a
a uh
really powerful speech
and
let's just let's just watch his this is
brian sutter's last words as a cnn host
here it is
here's what i do know i know it's not
partisan to stand up for decency and
democracy and dialogue it's not partisan
to stand up to demagogues it's required
it's patriotic we must make sure we
don't give platforms to those who are
lying to our faces
but we also must make sure we are
representing the full spectrum of debate
and representing what's going on in this
country and in this world
that's why cnn needs to be strong that's
why i believe cnn will always be strong
you you viewers at home it's on you
cnn must remain strong
i know the 4 500 staffers are going to
do their part to make it stronger than
ever but it's going to be on you
to hold cnn accountable and not just cnn
you got to hold your local paper
accountable you got to hold your local
digital outlet accountable it's on all
of us we are all members of the media
all helping to make it better
that's what i believe
i can't wait to be watching cnn seeing
what happens to in the future i'm going
to be rooting for it i want cnn to be
strong i believe america needs cnn to be
strong i believe the free world needs
cnn to be strong and it will continue to
be
because all of us are going to help make
that happen
the free world
needs a reliable source
so
for reliable sources for the last time
i'm brian stelter
thanks for being with us
oh man that was rough that was rough at
the end there that was rough with the
with the applause at the end it was it
was already sad and then you get the
he's better off without the people you
got one person applauding
that's bro i'm going to miss this guy
brian i will miss him i'll miss him may
you rest in peace
he is cnn is cnn must be strong cnn is
necessary for democracy cnn will save
the world cnn is the future of the world
i don't know for some reason
watching this it's probably just me but
i was reminded of the scene from the
office
where michael scott is giving a speech
at a business school and all the
students are telling him how you know
paper companies are obsolete and he says
no dunder mifflin is the future but
you're too stupid to see that and that's
that's it just it reminds me kind of
what stelter's doing here like cnn is
totally obsolete and irrelevant and and
nobody cares about it and he's clinging
on to it as humanity's last great hope
and he's doing that even after they just
canned his ass
it's just sad like first of all
you you get fired
and then they most of the time you work
for a media company if you get fired
they're you're not gonna be back on the
air
okay i can guarantee you if the daily
wire ever fired me they're not gonna let
me do one last show they would never let
me do that
because that would be a bad decision
when you fire someone and then let them
you give them access to your cameras one
last time when they've got nothing to
lose
but they let stelter do it because they
know he's a eunuch they know that he's
just gonna they could absolutely count
on him
to get up there and still
talk about how great cnn is
after they got rid of him and i feel bad
for him i really do
i feel bad because he's 35 but he looks
like a retired bus driver
and i feel bad for him in general
i won't even make any more potato jokes
about them i won't because it's you know
it's not bad to look like a potato
anyway that's the other thing i don't
think it's fair
there are worse root vegetables that you
could look like
imagine if you look like look like a
radish or
parsnips that would be pretty weird so
you know go easy on brian selter okay um
i want to mention this too it says from
fox news a private christian school in
florida told parents ahead of the coming
school year that students will only be
identified by their biological sex and
said that students who are found
participating quote unquote in gay or
transgender lifestyles will be asked to
leave the school immediately
the email sent by grace christian school
administrator barry mckeen says we
believe that god created mankind in his
image male man and female woman sexually
different but with equal dignity
therefore one's biological sex must be
affirmed and no attempt should be made
to physically change alter or disagree
with one's biological gender including
but not limited to elective sex
reassignment transvestite transgender or
non-binary gender fluid acts or conduct
students in school will be referred to
by the gender on their birth certificate
and be referenced in in name in the same
fashion
private christian school is located in
florida which is less than 20 miles
outside of tampa
and
of course this has sparked outrage
um
among many people on the left including
some of the people in the school and
parents are pulling their their
their kids out and all the rest of it
meanwhile this is of course
a wonderful thing
it's not going to surprise you to hear
me say that
this is a wonderful thing
and in fact if you here's what what you
need to do okay if you send your kid to
a private christian school and they have
not sent an email like that out
i'd be marching into the office
and print out a copy of this email and
say why haven't you sent this out
copy this email down put in your words a
little bit
send it out why haven't you
you know if if if you're paying money
in private christian schools most of
them uh i certainly know this are not
cheap
and if you're paying all that money
there should be a reason behind it and
the only reason i can think of just to
spend so much money to send your kid to
a private school instead of just sending
the public school is because
not just the education but the culture
is going to be vastly different from
what they get in public school
and of course they're in christian
school so you should expect that they
are being
introduced to and uh and brought up in
christian values
although in this case of course what he
just described in that email that i mean
those are christian values but they're
also that's also just reality
this is biblical values
male and female he created him
but that's also science and reality all
these things work together as they so
often do
so that would be my question
if i were sending my kid to a private
christian school have you sent an email
like that out and if you have it i want
to know why
except i'll you know you can already
assume why they haven't sent it out is
because they have no intention
of uh enforcing christian values in that
way and and they're perfectly happy to
let the insanity of modern culture
not only permeate into their christian
school environment but but define it
right
and
what about the people who are surprised
by this
parents
again paying money
to send your kid to a christian school
and then you're surprised when the
christian school says hey this is a
christian school and we're going to
operate accordingly
how could they be shocked by that
well it's only because we've gotten used
to this
idea
that lgbt people have the right to just
do whatever they want
and to do it anywhere in any situation
that they're entitled to it
that they're entitled to
living this life where people are
constantly making exceptions for them
you know talking about the speaking of
the bible they they are entitled to be
like moses
just parting the red sea everywhere they
go everywhere they go just everything
kind of parts and accommodates them and
make special exceptions
but that is simply not the reality
all right one one clip i want to play
this is from the director of the gender
development program in adolescent
medicine at lori children's hospital
libs of tick tock of course found this
and posted it here it is
you work with trans kids and teens and i
would love for you to share with people
um like a little window into what the
process is like when a family comes to
you um you know when kids realize
they're trans like what are they looking
for
when they meet with you is this a risky
process for a young person
yeah i mean
i mean the answer to that is largely
um no and yes you know so there are
things that we do not know
about the process but you know these are
medical interventions that have been
used for a long time now they've been
done quite safely
the medical interventions themselves are
not rocket science i mean these are
medications that we've used in other
conditions for many years that have a
really strong evidence base and so i
really want to be clear that i believe
these medicines can that can and are
used safely you know i know for a fact
that the teams that are out there that
are doing this work do it with a lot of
care and thought and precision
and so yes i mean there is there is not
a full range of evidence to support the
treatments that we're using
but there is a lot of anecdotal evidence
to support it and and the safety data
that's coming out really suggests that
these treatments can be used uh both
safe safely and appropriately
now it's important that i play all these
uh sorts of videos as they are found and
make their way into the public light
and because it's information that you
need but also because
all of these videos are going away okay
for for the last several years in fact
as we have discovered recently
especially
um
the people who are transing the kids
have been
at least amongst each other
have been relatively
open and honest about what they're doing
relatively
now the face they present to the world
is not honest at all the things they say
to the world is not on or not honest
because what they'll say the world is oh
all the evidence all the studies all the
evidence is there
so that's all a lie
but they have been kind of circulating
in their own little worlds
uh and being pretty honest with each
other
and saying things like that that's not
the only video we've seen just in the
last couple of weeks
say oh yeah there's we we don't have the
evidence for it it's anecdote
we we are going to surgically alter your
child permanently
based on anecdote
they've been saying this to each other
because up until now there's been no
accountability
and they know that there's kind of this
agreed upon
this this conspiracy of silence
certainly on the part of the media
so they know that they can talk amongst
each other they can have their like
seminars and forums and they can talk
kind of openly about it they can even
have interviews that they post on
youtube
and they know that the media is not
going to go dig these things up and tell
anyone about them
so they have the things they say to each
other even ostensibly in public because
they post it online and then they've got
but they think about the things that
they intend for the whole public to see
and they're very different
and they know that the media
is part of the conspiracy so the media
is going to take that stuff on the top
level the stuff that's intended for the
public and that's all they're going to
show us
but that agreement has broken down now
because what these
butchers and quacks are discovering is
that it's not up to the mainstream media
to decide what people see anymore
they used to be the only ones who decide
but not anymore
it doesn't work that way anymore
and so all those kinds of things are
going away
but it's still the truth
he said it
can't kind of think you can't take back
we don't have a range of evidence to
support these drastic surgical
interventions that we're doing to kids
can't take that back it's because it's
all it's true
the evidence isn't there
all right one other quick note here some
science for you today before we get to
the comments section the um the naso the
nasa exoplanet team tweeted out a video
which they say is the sound of a black
hole
so for the first time they were able to
capture what a black hole sounds like
this is this is real okay it's not like
they were now
it's real in certain senses it's not
like they were putting a tape recorder
up to the black hole and recording what
it sounds like they use a computer data
or something to come up with this i
don't know exactly how they do it
but
here is the actual sound of what a black
hole
it's like if you're getting sucked into
the black hole like matthew mcconaughey
in uh interstellar
he ended up behind a bookcase or
something somehow is that what happened
in that film but this is what it would
yeah he ended up behind a bookcase he
did
okay
anyway well this is what it would
actually happen this is what it would
sound like go ahead and play it
[Music]
so it
so it sounds basically like your deepest
nightmare has come to life it sounds
like a portal to hell and the thing i
love is that nasa tweeted this out like
a cool little bit of
a bit of trivia
they tweeted out like hey check it out
gang
and then the sound is it's the actual
sound of demons screaming from the pit
of hell
this is the sound that a possessed
person hears
as the evil spirit takes over it's just
the most viscerally disturbing sound and
nasa tweets it and says hey folks listen
to this neato
you know what that actually sounds like
this is actually the sound that i hear
whenever someone tries to make small
talk with me on an elevator i don't hear
the words i just hear sheer pain and
agony and despair
that's what that is
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
are you one of those people that plans a
trip but then immediately dreads the
thought of travel because you get motion
sick in the car plane train etc then
you're just like me and you've got to
check out relief bend relief band is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that's been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more a leaf ban stimulates a
nerve in the wrist that travels to the
part of the brain that controls nausea
and then blocks the signal your brain
sends to your stomach telling you that
you're sick relief band is a band that
you wear on your wrist to give you
relief from nausea just like it sounds
and you can even change the intensity
depending on how you're feeling to make
it stronger or weaker plus relief bend
is 100 drug free my favorite thing about
it is that it's non-drowsy and so you
can take it you don't have to worry
about being drowsy for the rest of the
day as is the case with other
anti-nausea um effort you know things
that you might use and they just
released their newest model which is
called relief band sport the sport is
waterproof has an extended battery life
and can even attach to your smartwatch
if you're finally taking that summer
trip this year i've got good news right
now you can get you can join the over
100 000 relief band users with an
exclusive offer just for my listeners go
to reliefband.com use promo code walsh
and you'll receive 20 off plus free
shipping with a no questions asked 30
day money back guarantee it's better to
have a relief ban and not need it than
to need it and not have it so go to
reliefband.com use promo code walls for
20 off plus free
shipping so how did matthew mcconaughey
end up behind the bookcase i need to i
saw the movie one time and i could never
remember if that's actually what
happened in the movie or did i dream it
or something but okay so he got sucked
into black hole and he ends up behind a
bookcase
and
it makes no sense that movie
interstellar can i just say was such a
i'm still mad about it it was such a
wasted opportunity i i've that's i've
probably never been as excited for a
film as i was for that one and i'm still
traumatized by how disappointed i was by
it uh because you know being a space
nerd like myself
um
i i thought well this is great i've been
waiting for a movie like this kind of a
science-based film they're going to
other solar systems and stuff and
they're exploring different planets but
then the whole movie is spent just
listening to anne hathaway give speeches
about the power of love and how it bonds
people together she's she's quoting like
pop lyrics the whole movie
and then it ends with the big grand
finale and he ends up behind a you know
an ikea bookshelf it just
total waste objective
that was a physical reality he could
understand that was a physical reality
he could understand
we'll talk about it in the post show
what does that mean
well how so how do you how do you end up
there because of a black hole we'll talk
about it in the member segment okay
you give that explanation like it's
supposed to make sense oh okay oh it's a
physical or addictive
so if you get sucked into a black hole
then it's going to present you with a
physical so a black hole is like a genie
or something a black hole will rip you
to shreds that's what never made it they
never explained why didn't the black
hole rip yourself it rips everything to
shreds it it annihilates light itself it
nihilists everything
except matthew mcconaughey he's the
exception
all right
um crazy scandi says matt walsh sang the
name hugh jar sol without hearing the
joke is hilarious i don't know what you
mean what joke
i read a comment from mr jarshl and i
responded to it
i don't know why you'd find that funny
make reality sane again says you okay
matt you seem tired and a bit more
fidgety than usual i know all this stuff
takes a toll on me when i'm exposed to
it day after day and you're under threat
constantly from the crazies
great episode either way take care
brother praying for you
well i was okay until i read that
comment now you made me feel
self-conscious
like there's nothing worse than that
when you feel perfectly fine and someone
comes up to you and says hey man you're
okay you look tired and haggard and
unkempt more than usual actually pretty
disgusting you doing okay
everything cool
well not anymore
thanks a lot
uh
you jarsol
rc tech says
hey matt perhaps you may you uh do not
realize in your everyday duties how many
people learn from you agree and support
you in latin america keep up the good
work not only for the usa but for the
west
well i do appreciate hearing that and
you know but i'm always shocked to learn
so you're telling me
down in latin america
so i i take it from that if they're if
like you're listening to me then i guess
you don't you don't go for the whole
latinx latinx america you're not
shocking
so you don't appreciate it when white
liberals the united states try to try to
give you a new language you have to
speak
on the logic that you're the new
language they're assigning to you
will make trans people feel better about
themselves so you don't appreciate that
really surprising
um
uh persimmon says this is the downside
of homeschooling matt has to do the work
of assigning his own children their
gender rather than just waiting for the
first grade teacher to decide for them
well it's not just gender though right
it's the public school system is happy
to decide everything for my child so
that's i gotta do i gotta do all you
know you homeschool you do it all
yourself because
if what the public school would love to
do is just give them
your child as a blank slate and they'll
create whatever they want
more than happy to do it
um
and finally bethany says matt
congratulations on the new babies will
you run the names by the sweet baby gang
so we can get a vote it may just come to
that my wife and i have been going back
and forth about this already and uh
we're already not seeing eye to eye um
for one thing she's advocating that one
of the kids be named matthew
but i'm trying to explain to her that
the ship has sailed on junior we can't
do the junior you can't do the junior
thing with a younger son i've got two
sons i can't leapfrog frog two sons
and then give junior to my third son on
my fourth son just doesn't you're asking
for all kinds of resentment and weird
dynamics down the line
plus i have made a number of very good
very serious suggestions that she has
shut down without even thinking about i
actually wrote out on friday night
i i was with my couple my kids and i was
writing out because all my kids have
written out lists of the names they want
and they said oh daddy you should write
so i wrote a list
and uh i
and we gave it to my wife she would she
like wouldn't even look at it
there are some good suggestions on there
um walter
gollum
uh sludge is one i thought sludge was
pretty good
very strong unique name for a boy
i looked at some up some uh egyptian
pharaohs and uh there's one uh there was
one called khufu
good name
honestly i don't know why my wife wants
to keep having kids because this this
she knows it'll go this way this is all
i will do for nine months is come up
with joke names
and the gag isn't even funny anymore it
was hardly funny when i did it with the
first set of twins but i'll just keep
doing it and every conversation she'll
try to have for the next nine months
it's like seriously can we talk about
names now and all i'm gonna do is throw
out fake names
and i can't i know it's not funny but i
can't i can't i have to it's like i have
this responsibility i don't know why
it's a
medical compulsion i think all right
let's get to the daily cancellation
[Music]
you know here at the daily wire we're
doing everything we can to loosen the
left's grip on culture we're making
movies that challenge woke hollywood
narratives documentaries like what is a
woman that exposed gender ideology we're
creating kids content parents can trust
we even sued the government over
unconstitutional mandates we're doing a
lot of stuff and it's a lot of work and
there's still a long way to go but you
can help in just two simple steps you
could do this these are the steps one
stop shaving with your wilk razor two
start shaving with jeremy's razor hold
up razor
oh
this is seamless don't cut any of this
keep the solder we need all this we need
the whole experience oh it's still okay
so i wasn't told i have to use a prop
and every it's like over here it's in a
bag it's in a box
so we're just gonna
we're just gonna oh and the razor isn't
even it's not it's not even assembled so
we have to assemble it too
live on camera don't cut this is all
staying in i'm telling you right now
there we go
another thing is i don't even really use
razors except for jeremy's razors so i'm
just i'm getting used to
just the process how do you get this
thing on okay
oh here we go good
you can help daily wire by shaving with
jeremy's razors if you're still not
shaving with jeremy's razors chances are
you're funding the left we're building
alternatives and the left is betting
their bottom billion dollars that you
won't use these alternatives prove them
wrong go to jeremysrazers.com get your
founder serious shave kit today daily
wire plus members get 25 off as well
jeremy's razors
shut up and shave now let's get to our
daily cancellation
well our culture is the most popular
pastime as we know is complaining
especially about stress you know the
idea of stress as we know it today
wasn't invented in the english language
until the 1930s before that it's fair to
say that nobody ever complained about
their stress because the concept didn't
really exist that's not to say that
people didn't feel stressed or didn't
lead stressful lives it's just to say
that they that they simply lived those
lives and dealt with the strain
without feeling the need to put a label
on it and talk about it incessantly
these days though by most measures we
have easier lives we love nothing more
than to talk about our difficulties
we're so burned out
we have so much anxiety so much stress
everything is so hard and we need to
talk about this to our friends our
families to strangers on the internet to
counselors and therapists i mean we've
got armies of people we've set up
to just complain to them about how hard
our lives are
we have to vomit our feelings of being
overburdened onto everyone
everywhere all the time this is without
question the modern world's favorite
hobby
now our second favorite hobby is to come
up with trendy new labels for common
human experiences so we like to take
things that people have always done
and or always felt they're always said
and invent a term to describe it so that
we can pretend that this universal
experience is somehow novel
so for example
um recently i came across the term
flexitarian to describe people who eat
both vegetables and meat
this is a diet strategy shared by 99 of
the human civilization since the dawn of
civilization but now the flexitarian can
pretend that he's reinvented the wheel
by giving this exceedingly normal thing
a brand new name
in fact i'm surprised we haven't come up
with a new name four wheels so that we
can pretend that we actually did
reinvent them
maybe we'll get around to that
eventually as we seem to specialize in
the art of inventing things that were
already invented but what happens when
these two popular pastimes are combined
what if we could whine about our
stressful lives while also inventing a
new label for something people have
always done
what if we could do both that would be
the modern
uh dream that's the holy grail
and that's what brings us to the hot new
trend called quiet quitting
now the media tells us that quiet
quitting is a revolutionary concept
quickly gaining traction in society and
especially in the workplace uh the
headlines are full of references to this
practice here's some samples of the
headlines quiet quitting is a trend
taking over tiktok and your workplace
everyone is talking about quiet quitting
but is it a good idea
three millennials on their experience of
quiet quitting
what is quiet quitting and why are
employees doing it and explainer
the washington post provides more detail
it says quiet quitting is taking social
media by storm but you might not have
noticed the term is a bit of a misnomer
because quiet quitters aren't walking
away from their jobs instead they're
renouncing hustle culture quitting the
idea of going above and beyond at work
as tick-tock user
zade lepin
oh that's what he did there set in a
july post that has amassed more than
three million views and helped
popularize the phrase the trend is
resonating strongly with those gen z and
millennial
workers fighting to rewrite the rules of
the workplace signs of quiet quitting
look like classic indicators of
diminished motivation and low engagement
according to joe grasso senior
director of workplace transformation at
lyra health
that might be decreased productivity or
withdrawing from the team limiting
communication and interaction to only
what's required graso said
it could manifest as employee cynicism
or apathy about work or staying silent
rather than sharing input
now the article goes on to explain that
quiet quitting is the result of quote
unprecedented employee burnout
people are feeling more burned out and
overworked than ever before allegedly
this has led to the quiet quitting trend
wherein employees in defiance of
something called hustle culture decide
to go to work but put in less effort
they'll do only the bare minimum and no
more
they'll work but they won't work hard as
mentioned this is a major type of
conversation on tick tock especially
where people are too burned out to do
their jobs
but not too burned out to record tick
tock videos talking about how burned out
they are so here's one viral tick tock
video
giving more details about this
revolutionary new concept
everybody's talking about quiet quitting
and how it's the new negative talent
crisis
i think it's a good thing
the youngest generations at work are
rejecting the idea of hustle culture or
framing your entire life around some
dream job
they're rejecting putting their mental
health below their performance goals
with quiet quitting you're doing what
you're paid for and not more
and it's about setting boundaries around
what you're willing to do
if the inflation rate is eight and a
half percent and you get a one percent
raise
what do employers expect
i see this as a healthy evolution that
can actually equalize the employee
employer relationship more
do you think quiet quitting is a good
thing
let me know
okay
so a few points here
first of all
doing the bare minimum at work is not
some unique quirky new approach to life
we don't need a label for it
we already had a label it's called lazy
and lazy people have always existed
in fact they made a movie called office
space over 20 years ago about exactly
this idea i think this is my second
office space reference at as many shows
the protagonist feels drained by his
soul-sucking office job and decides to
stop trying and hilarity ensues
but office space didn't invent anything
either in fact what makes the movie
funny is that it's relatable
everybody knows what it's like to be fed
up with your job you know and and to be
fed up with other various mundane
aspects of your life everybody is
fantasized about adopting and i don't
give a damn attitude
everyone is especially fantasized about
smashing office appliances with a
baseball bat as they do in that film
the point is that millennials and gen z
aren't sparking a revolution here
they're experiencing
the only difference is that they're
narcissistic enough to think they
invented it
second um if if you want to do the bare
minimum
that's fine okay
that's uh that's mediocrity
and if you want to live a mediocre life
you're welcome to it
many people before you have chosen that
path and many people after you will do
the same that's why it's mediocrity
just just don't pretend that you're
putting in less of an effort at your job
so that you can invest more of your time
into more enriching pursuits and
passions now that may be what a very
small fraction of the quiet quitters do
but it's not how it works for the vast
majority
as we discussed last week most people
who give themselves more free time end
up spending all of that extra spare time
staring at their phones or watching
netflix
now if you're actually going to
take all the free time take all the
extra energy you have now because you
are quiet quitting and go climb mount
everest
or start a side business or even like
take painting classes or something then
then okay
you are reinvesting your time and energy
into another uh pursuit that to you is
more worthwhile
but that is just simply not what most
people do or are going to do and we
should be honest about that
and you should be honest with yourself
and if you're doing the bare minimum at
work refusing to go above and beyond and
not pursuing anything else notable with
your life
then you will be unsuccessful and again
mediocre that's who you're going to be
that's what your life is going to be
you will not flourish financially or in
any other way
you're going to leave little mark on the
world you'll achieve nothing of note
that is going to be your life
now the luxury of the modern world does
provide people with the unprecedented
option of coasting by on the bare
minimum if they want expending very
little energy
this was not a lifestyle available to
most people for most of history now it
is available
you can take advantage of that
opportunity and you can if you want but
it does come with a price nothing is
free even laziness is not free
especially laziness is not free
not in this life
being lazy will extract a payment from
you whether you like it or not and what
you are giving up in exchange for ease
of life is any chance of doing anything
notable interesting or great with your
life
because the notable interesting and
great things are done by people who give
more of themselves than is required
the great lives are led by those who
look for ways to give more not less
this is also true just just you know in
the microcosm of the workplace
for the most part the people who succeed
okay are the ones who are giving giving
more so you're just doing exactly what
you need to the guy next to you is doing
a lot more than he needs to he's
probably gonna be more successful than
you
and then when he is you're gonna whine
about it and say oh it's not fair this
isn't fair
actually it's totally fair
that's possible there could be someone
who's awarded with success even though
they didn't earn it and you did these
that kind of unfairness really does
happen
but but probably that's not the case
probably that's a story you're telling
yourself to make yourself feel better
probably that person earned it
and you didn't
and in general the great people are the
ones who do hard things not the ones who
avoid hard things that's a fact of life
it will never change
so all i'm asking
you'll be a quiet quitter fine don't
come around later complaining about your
lack of success don't become envious of
the people more successful to you you
wanted to quiet quit okay you wanted to
put in less effort you aimed low and you
got what you wanted
you have no right to resent people who
aimed higher than you
third and final point related to the
first two points
i am not suggesting that you should stay
forever in a job you hate pouring
yourself into it year after miserable
year if you if you hate your job and you
feel unfulfilled by it
if you feel that it's not making use of
your talents if you think it's a dead
end etc then go chase something better
if if you just don't want to work at all
then you're a lazy overgrown child and
as long as you maintain that attitude
you're destined as previously discussed
to be a mediocre failure and a disgrace
and embarrassment to your family and
everyone who knows you but if you're
willing to work and yet you feel that
your work right now is wasted or futile
or pointless
then go and pursue a new opportunity and
yeah you can make a scale i can't do
that i can't do it for all these you can
make excuses all you want i can't do it
it's a risk if i do that if i do it it
won't work out if i gotta get this i
have a family
those are those are excuses and i mean
they might even be valid
but once again the people who do great
things are not focused on the excuses or
they act in spite of them
staying at your job and trying to do the
bare minimum is the coward's way out
that's what the guy in office space
discovered by the end of the film he had
left the office world completely found
happiness as a construction worker
he found work that was meaningful to him
and that's what you should do
because that's professional success
right there isn't a certain salary you
have to reach in order to be successful
professionally what matters is whether
you're doing work that is meaningful to
you and which utilizes your talents
skills and efforts
that's success
and it's a lot better than being a lazy
bum
also known as a quiet quitter
and that's why quiet quitting
as a concept and especially also just as
a label
is cancelled today
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move on to uh the special
members section of the show we'll see
you over there and if not godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you